hey guys what's up now there's been a
lot of you that asked me hey Daniel
please give me a few tips to be more
attractive not just look attractive but
to be more attractive or just to look a
little bit better so in this video I'm
gonna give you 23 tips to be more
attractive and if you stick until the
end I'll give you a bonus tip as well so
let's get into the video
[Music]
alright now let's be honest whether you
are single and still looking for that
special girl out there or if you already
have someone we guys we want to be more
attractive to them right well luckily
there are always things that you can
improve on to make yourself better or
more attractive so let's start with tip
number one always dress just a little
bit better than the situation requires
don't overdress or underdressed be
self-confident focus on your strengths
and remember you are unique so remember
to smile relax and keep your composure
in all situations
always use deodorant and find a very
good cologne that suits you when you
find it use it every day and pretty soon
people will identify that smell with you
if you're not sure which colognes to use
I'll add a few of my favorites in a
video description so you can check it
out never have bad breath it's a lot of
guys out there they flash and brush
their teeth every day which is great but
they forget about their tongue if you
have this white kind of discolouring
on your tongue then chances are you have
bad breath so scrape it off avoid
looking like you've been trying too hard
with your clothing styles the people who
dress the best looks like they've just
happened to put these clothing styles on
and they're they're cool they don't look
like they've been obsessing over it
remember it's not just what you wear
it's how you wear it
adopt a habit of walking and sitting
with a straight back if you strengthen
the muscles in your back it will make it
a lot easier so don't skip those back
exercises at the gym
start to use a good face cream every day
you will protect you against the Sun and
ultimately those wrinkles that will make
you look older than you really are if
you don't really know which products to
use I'll add a few of my favorites in
the video description be more empathetic
towards others and less selfish think
about the feelings and interests of
other people a lot more because that
will ultimately help you to communicate
with them a lot better it's like good
care of your shoes apart from making you
look better cleaning and polishing your
shoes every now and then will make the
shoes last longer and save you money
if you wear socks make sure the socks
match the pants and please throw away
all the socks with the holes in them
yeah you know what I'm talking about
playing your ears for those guys that
have those hair poking out of the years
yes that also means you got a trimming
if you feel that your face is not that
attractive like the symmetry is not all
there what you can do is grow a cool
beard style some men look a lot better
with a beard it's like they've been born
to wear one
so why shave it we'll just trim it
stolid and maintain it
stop wearing stuff that are meant for
specific tasks like for example
flip-flops they're meant for the beach
and the pool hiking boots for hiking
I feel like I almost don't have to say
but you got to start eating better your
body will thank you for it and you will
not only look better you will feel
better as well if you're not sure what
to eat check out my male model diet plan
after this video
all right another tip that I almost feel
like I don't really want to mention
because it's kind of common sense but
you gotta exercise if you hate exercise
try just two days a week one hour or get
a bike or start the new sport just get
moving you will really start to have
more energy and you will also feel a lot
better
and then clothes will look a lot better
on you as well
have at least one pair of good classic
oxford shoes and someone else is talking
especially if it's a girl give your full
attention
think about it how do you feel like if
you've been talking for a while and you
just realized this person doesn't listen
to you at all and also never interrupt
someone else when they are talking
because then they will feel disrespected
[Music]
when you go shopping bring a brutally
honest friend that you can trust if they
tell you hey this outfit is not looking
good don't be angry they're just trying
to help you
never ask a salesperson that are there
because they need to make their
Commission rather trust your friend
choose the right haircut for your face
remember your face is also changing over
time go and look at some old photos and
you'll see it this also means that the
hairstyle that used to work for you
might not work for you anymore if you're
a happy with your haircut use the right
styling products there's a huge
difference between pomades waxes gels
hair spray cream and clay and hey if
you're not sure which products to use
check out my best options in the video
description another tip I almost feel
like I don't have to really say it
because common sense but improve your
clothing styles sometimes the clothes do
make the man especially when it comes to
first impressions so a good tip is to
avoid clothes there are two types for
too big if you're not sure what to use
again check out the video description be
friendly kind and positive because one
of the most robust findings in
psychology is the halo effect and what
is the halo effect well it is basically
a bias where you unconsciously take one
aspect of somebody as a proxy for their
overall character in other words you
basically make an assumption of their
whole personality based on only one
aspect now it's interesting that
research studies shown that people who
are more kind of positive and friendly
are rated as being more attractive than
other people
be yourself in all situations
why well basically let me explain in
this way being original is worth more
than a copy if you get what I mean
you can always improve on yourself but
never try to be someone that you're not
because you're never meant to be someone
else you're supposed to be the only you
in this world
[Music]
all right the bonus step this is
probably the most important tip that a
lot of people out there forget
especially in the world that we live in
today what is it it is that beauty is
not just about having a pretty face it's
about having a pretty mind a pretty
heart and a pretty soul and remember
having a kind and soft heart in a cruel
world is not a weakness it's courage all
right if you liked the video give it a
thumbs up subscribe and click the
notification bell so you won't miss any
of the next videos that's it guys Cheers